so it is now being alleged and it seems
pretty damn clear that Donald Trump's
big powerful squinting at the camera
strong-looking Situation Room photo that
was supposedly taken while the raid that
led to the suicide of Isis leader Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi was happening was a
staged photograph likely taken hours
after the event and that Donald Trump
was actually playing golf when the raid
took place I already told you that
Donald Trump admits to having told the
Russians but not House leadership about
the attack in advance I also already
discussed how that puts our national
security at risk it puts our sovereignty
at risk we don't need to go back to that
we did that already let's just talk
about the picture briefly my BS detector
was going crazy as soon as I saw this
picture it seemed so obvious that this
was another element of Trump trying to
recreate barack obama's osama bin laden
moment with the picture from the
Situation Room with the speech that he
gave and with all of it the picture
looks completely staged to anyone with
common sense everyone looks like they're
posing it was posted by dance Covino
scavino x' and assistant to trump and
director of social media and of course
the trumpets ate this up like it was
being spoon-fed to them but then it very
quickly started getting weird Pete Souza
who's a photographer he's been a
photographer for numerous presidents
ending with Barack Obama
notice that the raid took place at 3:30
p.m. Eastern Time Washington DC time and
the IPTC data on this photograph says
that the picture was taken at 1705
that's 505 p.m. about 90 minutes 95
minutes after the raid took place now
put that aside for a second just looking
at the picture suggests that it's staged
do you see everyone clearly posed the
picture is symmetrical it looks it one
of the pictures looks like it's being
taken in a way that would actually block
the view of everyone in the room of what
it is that they are supposedly they are
observing it looks like a setup
there's the now-infamous picture of
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton and Joe
Biden taken during the raid that killed
Osama bin Laden
it actually looks like a real candid
picture with people reacting in
real-time to what's going on rather than
a staged photo op 90 minutes after the
incident is over now it's possible and
it's been discussed that was the raid
still going on more than 90 minutes
later but the idea that they'd be in
that pose after 90 minutes late 90
minutes after the raid ended is strange
to say the least
but then we get more information it is
now believed that Donald Trump was
golfing at 333 p.m. Washington DC time
the raid was at 3:30 Trump golfing at
333 how was he in the Situation Room
watching this live there are reports
that Donald Trump's motorcade started
coming back to the White House after
4:15 p.m. Eastern Time once again
suggesting the Situation Room picture
had to have been staged long after the
fact now in reality this shouldn't
matter because there are so many things
that really do matter a lot here why did
Donald Trump tell Russians before
congressional leadership about this raid
was this operation legal always a
question when US military operations are
happening in other countries does taking
out one person in Isis even really
matter in the fight against Isis since
it is cell based and decentralized and
more ideological than about individual
leaders does this really undo the damage
that Trump did in the region by pulling
troops from northern Syria instantly
endangering the Kurds there are real
issues to talk about but understand how
none we've become to Donald Trump's
character that a totally staged
Situation Room photo is released we
found out that he was actually playing
golf at the time and were completely
desensitized to it I've said before the
further Trump is from making decisions
it's better in a sense we should be glad
that Trump was nowhere near the
Situation Room when this raid was
happening his presence could only have
worsened the possible outcomes if he
wasn't golfing he might have been
tweeting about it as it was happening
right I mean it's really not good for
Trump to be near these things but this
is just not somebody who's in it to help
the country
this is not someone who's here to better
circumstances for as many Americans as
possible or to be a participant in this
thing we know as humanity on planet
Earth for the betterment of as many
people as possible he's in it for
himself
golfing self enrichment staging a
picture that he thinks makes him look
look good even though the picture is
obviously staged it's sick and
geopolitically the most serious thing
and I mentioned this but it's it's
really where the focus of our
conversation should be killing leaders
of terrorist groups doesn't do that much
in 2019
there is an environment and a
geopolitical status quo that foments the
ideologies that lead to things like Isis
that's what you need to change if you
kill a leader or you show up and you get
a leader to kill themselves and three of
their kids has happened the number two
is promoted and that's it and lastly as
a reminder for this week of gloating by
Donald Trump that I hope you're ready
for remember what Donald Trump said back
in 2012 Donald Trump tweeted in 2012
stop congratulating Obama for killing
bin Laden the Navy SEALs killed bin
Laden I wonder I wonder if Donald Trump
is going to apply that exact same logic
to what took place here particularly
since he was golfing as this raid was
being carried out and his involvement
could only have put the operation at
risk without helping anything at all let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman while you're there follow the
show on twitter at david pakman show and
make sure you follow me on Twitch
because we are back to live streams this
week at twitch.tv slash David Pakman the
David Pakman show is possible thanks to
sponsors like VIN Chara watches giving
everyone in our audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch I just got a
couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my
really great choice I also picked out
the VIN Charo bellwether in silver and
white and what I love about this one
number one the Roman numeral at the top
of the face the white face is great this
is a chronograph model and I love the
blue leather band it's just a really
nice looking watch everybody who sees me
wear this one always asks about it what
I like about Vince arrow as a watch
brand is you're getting quality and
you're getting a watch where it's clear
as soon as you open the box that a lot
of care and artisanship went into the
design and the way that the watch is put
together I'm not interested in paying
thousands of dollars for a watch when I
can get one that's reasonably priced and
looks just as nice and has terrific
build quality and that's exactly what
Vince arrow is in the business of doing
putting a ton of craftsmanship into
their watches making them available for
a hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
you really can't go wrong check them out
at david pakman.com slash watch support
the people who support our show and
you'll save fifteen percent when you use
that link